خلال نصف قرن اتغير كل شيء في اليابان ضل
ثابت وحيد وهو ميزانيه الدفاع الاتفاق
الانفاق لم يتخطا الواحد في المئه من
الناتج المحلي ولو لمره واحده
غير رسميه عام 1976 للتركيز على البنيه
التحتيه وتطور المدني لكن استمر تغير حقبه
اليوم باستقتاباتها انقساماتها الحاده
وبشراره اطلق على جاره بعيده
العاصمه تقع في وسط بيئه امنيه هي الاكثر
قسوه وتعقيدا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
المقصد موجود ولكن في مياه اليابان التي
بقيت راكده لسنوات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اي شيء
ادركنا التاريخي بلوى نقطه تحول الرئيسيه
خطتها اليابان في ثلاثه وثائق امنيه مهمه
بعنوان الاستراتيجيه الشامله تسمح لها بان
تكون دوله طبيعيه مره اخرى والوصف لمجله
بتبثومات الامريكيه لماذا طبيعيه لانها
حصلت اخيرا على ضوء الاخضر يتملك قدرات
هجوميه كصواريخ توماهوك الامريكيه تمكينها
من ضرب قواعد صواريخ العدو الضوء اخضر
مع التوافق مع معايير حلفائها فيتو
بالارقام الميزانيه الدفاع اليابانيه
ارتفعت بمعدل 65% ووصلت الى
314 مليار دولار امريكي رقم النقل البلاد
الى نادي الكبار المنفقين عسكريا لتصبح
الثالثه بعد امريكا والصين بعد الصين صحيح
لكنها قريبه جدا وتراقبها جيدا اذا نقلتها
في وثائقها الثلاث من وصفها بقضيهم
المجتمع الدولي عام 2013 الى التحدي
الاستراتيجي الاكبر لليابان وذلك في عام
رغم ذلك تتمنى اليابان المواقف غامضه تجاه
الصين ربما لانها غير مستعده بعد للتضحيه
بمعجزه النهضه التي حققتها بعد مسح اثار
القنبلتين واحلي عقدته
هنا استسلم
لتبدا مرحله مرحله
نصف القرن انها اليوم
وثائق اليابان رسائل تقراوها بيونجا وبكين
بحذر وان كانت لم ترفع الحظر عن طوكيو من
شان ضربه انسبقيه لكنها تشكل جزءا من اراد
عن اكبر قبل سنه مهدت امريكا الطريق
لتحالف العسكري بدا بشراكه امنيه ثلاثيه
عرفت بي اوكس امريكا بريطانيا واستراليا
مهمته الفعليه ضبط ميزان القوه في منطقه
المحيط الهادئ
التحالف استفز الخصوم خطه تسليح استراليا
بالغواصات النوويه تحديدا وحتى الخلفاء
والمنافسين توجسون من ان يدفع التحالف
لسباقي تسلح في المنطقه ويفضي لحربا بحريه
بارده مع الوقت بدا ان العز لا تحيط
بالحلف في وقت تحوط فيه الصين بشركاء
استراتيجيين بين دول وجزر المنطقه ولا على
سبب العزله في انفس
من اي صوت اسيويه ومن هنا اختلف التكتيك
دخلت الهند واليابان على الخط الخارجي
للحلف وان كان بصوره غير رسميه عبر
اتفاقيات وتعاون وتدريبات المشتركه مع
استراليا توسيع الجبهه يزيد من التحديات
امام الصين ليس امنيا فقط وانما الضغط
عليها واجبارها على تقديم تنازلات
اقتصاديه وتجاريه وربما لفرد التسويه تخدم
اطراف المنطقه
صناعه اليوم لا تحصره اتفاقيه وسلاح فقط
بل اتفوقا تقنيا واستخباراتيا واقتصادي
وفضائي وصعود الصين في هذه المجالات تحدن
خطر لمكانه ونفود الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها في العالم